how scum rose my name is Pierre I've
been traveling so much lately bras last
week I was in LA now I'm in Italy
because month I wanted to go see your
family
this is where I used to record all my
stuff this is where it all began not
really and I used to be in here because
it was better acoustics in here
remember the sink remember the sink
friends oh yeah it's good to be back
la was so much fun Bianca tournament was
so much fun I had a blast I got to hang
out with a bunch of youtubers I got to
hang out with Ken and then it was just a
really fun thing I really enjoyed it
thanks to everyone being part of it so I
wanted to share with you bros like I
said the training with the two Anki
experts I'm a little rusty but I took it
very seriously so we was enjoying it
comes welcome to the first ever
Anki Drive battle Grand Prix
Evan Sonova tips is next off Beauty game
grump pop and dunk going blue Aaron in
here ken is next crew shrug so now we're
going to get on to the one-on-one
sessions where we meet with each of one
of you individually and get into some
more deeper tactics and then evaluate
your driving style and that'll help us
decide how the brackets are going to go
welcome pewds to your one-on-one
training thank you see what car you
choose well like I said since I'm
Swedish I went for the blue and well
it's golden but I'll make an exception
it's yours cat all
[Music]
no sorry it's okay
yeah I'll forgive didn't mean that back
of course today are using your special
ability you know all the time okay oh no
did I get you yeah I got you okay I
gotta try to tell skewed at least one
yeah you're one day where's Cory here we
come
that's a good maneuver oh it almost
worked okay carnac's just being a dick
yeah I mean afraid ha ha I hate gorac
but I also have besides the boost I have
kinetic break which makes me extra gravy
stop if you have I have to sub come on
we're gonna get to upgrade after this so
there's my kinetic break this yeah leads
me to stop on a dime I'll go up there
here'll their rights Camry oldest team
up against core ex he's like the real
enemy here ok so let's go ahead go ahead
just kidding your day no this time I got
second I'll take second pretty good
technique already I can see there so now
we're gonna go ahead and move on to
bottleneck where you're gonna fight just
against the AI Oh we'll be able to
address you techniques are a little bit
more and give you some pointers
so now we're on bottleneck which is one
of our expansion tracks we're going to
be doing a race to 15 here it's all
about just winning the time of course
before we were on the starter pack and
we were doing battling so this would be
a nice contrast before we dig into that
though we gave you 35,000 points Oh
which is a metric buttload of point and
you're gonna be able to use a small
portion that right now to pick your
first uh-oh
so let's go your way the garage I'll get
I'll get a better shield why not I'll
probably get hard armor okay sounds good
okay energy better coordinate yeah there
you go yeah feels good energy
improvement is great a lot of this game
comes down to watching your energy I'll
get a look using your weapons at the
right time okay am I ready to go I think
you are ready so cute you've got your
favorite car qatal there you already did
some battle now you're gonna do some
racing just against the AI okay he
selected a couple of upgrades for
yourself I did so now we're just gonna
let you go at it against the AI so
Harold and I can evaluate yeah bang
creep you're gonna judge how about it
yes you got our fifteen laps or so no
pressure then
okay guys millions millions of people
watching me I know just being me okay
all right I'll show you I'll show you
no come on
yeah those pinch points on the
bottleneck are tough so typical deli
that will definitely come in handy in
the balla grand prix what are you doing
as you come up on those pinch points
maybe pulling back a little bit okay
it's a battle no and why are they so
mean there we go no no no no no I say
that is like Lobster I mean AI thinks
this is a smash them up derby stage I'm
second Sakura I can do it oh there you
go you fell asleep
Michael Rex get back in it yeah he
doesn't need it potala pony what else
all right now you're actually doing
pretty well
yeah thank you now man something really
smart is you're not over steering
a lot of times I get to exactly excited
I forgot I could wear this right thanks
oh god why is he doing
suta gang I'm shilling now should i /
shilling that that's pretty girls a good
time I ran out ready winner you're
shielding or using your guns sure hold
on a sailor today you want to hold down
instead of tap okay okay I totally got
him there all right no nevermind hey got
me now oh I'm fourth now come on
all right just wait is it medium or
shirts media everything okay number one
weather yeah just John are two spots
still do not move
you're still here second I got I got the
skills
you work for thank you all right good
job makin again I think I couldn't be
the chosen one
considering you're got Haiti on in the
field and need the fastest car on the
track which one is that that's the
orange one uh so not bad so you a couple
of really good things that are going to
come in handy in a battle cram free ok
not over steering so I'm very economical
on your steering I remember I'm gonna
give you a high response time it's all
about safety yeah and good switching
between your shield and your weapon
that's gonna come in really here I think
if they stay too close to the edge that
also slows them down then the right
answer takes me of that ok I just got my
driver license from the DRB if you want
to be cool like me of course you do
check out the link in description and
sign up and you can get one as well
alright so that was my training next up
is the tournament you definitely don't
want to miss ever us it's going to be
awesome so stay tuned for that rose
don't forget to leave a like and I will
see you in the next one as always stay
awesome bros
[Music]